so now what do I do huh
you know I can't fight I don't drink I
don't smoke cigars you know I don't know
about this [ __ ] helicopter [ __ ] now
you know people are all my friends
everybody's you guys stop doing you guys
stop doing it so if I stop doing that
what the [ __ ] do I do it out what do
what do I do
people if I'm not killing myself or
attempting to kill myself how do I fill
the day that is my question you know
what I'm gonna look up right now I'm
gonna look up sober life activities
sober life activities alright alright
now I got my eyes shut I'm not looking
I'm gonna let's I'm gonna try to guess
they probably had will have 10 I'm gonna
try to guess some join a sports league
take up a hobby get into cooking take a
cooking class join a gym go on walks
watch some live music take a vacation
whatever they say alright
substance abuse spent 30 funds 30 99
things to do
when you're sober throw a sober dinner
party oh yeah I gotta tell all you users
out there man this is the fun you're
missing throw a sober dinner party
invite your closest friends over for
dinner and dessert substitute alcoholic
beverages for delicious and refreshing
fruit infused cocktails pick a playlist
with piano or classic tones to keep the
vibe classy and elegant
check out Spotify has already made
playlists according to the mood or genre
alright [ __ ] that rejuvenating spa day
at home solo or with friends
quite a few girlfriends over for
tea I like this couple chicks over I got
a massage out of this what's going on
here is this Ford women only watch
movies and give each other
manicure and pedicures don't forget the
face masks and hair conditioning
treatments - this is a fun way to pamper
yourself and help improve your parents
at the same time okay all right number
three guys night out slash girls night
out plan a weekend to go camping fishing
or to a sporting event in town I would
go camping or fishing I wouldn't go to a
sporting event and you watch everybody
else getting shit-faced having a good
time uh exercise run box do yoga huh
okay I got this one here we go hot yoga
hike swim anything just get out there
stretch it out break a sweat
exclamation yeah [ __ ] this go for a
drive bubble baths not just for women
hey Bill you don't drink half a bottle
of bourbon any more what are you doing
said is there anything more boring than
taking a [ __ ] bath jesus [ __ ]
christ and he just sitting there in your
own filth in that [ __ ] dirty water
and it's just so goddamn hot I always
feel like you know this must be what
it's like you know the first five
minutes you know if you accidentally
encountered a tribe of cannibals and
Ellie Stuckey in the pot like at first
it's like bathwater oh this is nice
they're so friendly play a game of golf
what us good side dishes is for eating a
human being
play a game of golf or practice your
swing at the driving range oh my god
go for a drive meditate read a book go
see a movie
volunteer your time and services that's
probably the most productive one to get
yourself out of your own [ __ ] head
play basketball
yeah great go blow out your [ __ ]
Achilles go swimming go for a
[ __ ] and smile at every person you
pass by oh great hey how are you sober
psycho write in your journal create a
new playlist for yourself or as a gift
for someone else oh my god this is just
showing this is showing why people get
[ __ ] up plan a garden organize and
clean out your closet and donate at
least ten items this thing's all over
the map are you trying to make me not be
a hoarder or very [ __ ] this thing this
person claims 99 things to do sober clip
your toenails see if you can get it in
all one piece no sorry go to local
cinema subscribe to TV streaming service
watch to your heart's content watch all
the Golden Globes and Oscar nominees for
Best Picture revisit all seasons of Game
of Thrones before the final season watch
all ten seasons of friends oh my God why
would you do any of this to yourself put
on a movie marathon buy a crossword
puzzle book learn ballet or tap-dancing
I would learn tap-dancing because I just
think would be [ __ ] hilarious if in
secret you became really great at
tap-dancing and then when you just
busted it out you know put on Yankee
Doodle Dandy that done didn't did then
you do the big windmill people like what
in the [ __ ] is going on and you just
have this crazy smile on your face
go ballroom dancing watch Cirque de
Soleil go to a theme park like
Disneyland dress up and attend the Opera
attend an art exhibit listen to songs of
all your favorite singers in one night
better than getting boozed man sing in a
karaoke place in front of a lot of
people play board games I'm gonna start
crying go on an alcohol free food trip
relax in a bubble bath have breakfast in
bed
date your fashion sense read celebrity
websites and keep up with the
Kardashians this is all why people drink
this is really pathetic run around the
neighborhood and really nice running
shoes oh yeah this is so much better
than heroin sign up for a gym membership
try out trendy workouts like CrossFit or
under water aerobics I swear to god this
isn't a joke go bowling go bowling my
god that's ten lanes of [ __ ] booze
bags all right here's one that does last
one I read this one's throwing down 20
sober activities that are more fun than
using drugs or drinking these [ __ ]
[ __ ] say bubble bath
do you like team sports there are
leagues for bowling softball touch flag
football soccer hockey Oh playing hockey
could be fun
start reading oh yeah that's way better
than [ __ ] you know taking DMT and
seeing what the other universe looks
like sit down and read [ __ ] George
and them [ __ ] man with the yellow hat
visit a hobby or craft shop join a gym
take classes at your local YMCA start an
online course start an offline that is
to say it happens in the real world
course find public gardens in your area
visit a zoo or an aquarium oh yeah
nothing makes me [ __ ] forget about
booze like an imprisoned animal
volunteer that's a good one learned how
to write songs alright okay you know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna finish this
podcast and I'm gonna go right to a
goddamn liquor store wow that was a big
[ __ ] swing and a Miss the the read
the reality is I don't want to say what
I'm going to say cuz it's too goddamn
negative about sobriety alright I'm
sorry I apologize for all of that [ __ ]
I'll tell you what's great about being
sober is waking up having not drink
that's [ __ ] great
and I'm not gonna lie to you it is
[ __ ] great till about 4:00 4:30 in
the afternoon and then it sucks until
you go to sleep all right
that's the truest [ __ ] I can tell you
about it okay good luck all right
and they're hearing enough bubble baths
in the [ __ ] world and Spotify
playlists and [ __ ] fruity sober
[ __ ] drinks that you can drink that
can make up for that